غضب شعبي متزاين ومشاهد نادره الاحتجاجات
هي الاولى من نوعها في اقليم سينغ يانج
غربيه الصين الحشود تهتف انه الاغلاق
والمتهم حريق في مبنى شاهق سببه اجراءات
اغلاقات مرتبطه بمكافحه فيروس كورونا حريق
دفع المحتاجين الى النزول الى شوارع
اورميتشي في اقليم الشينغ للتعبير عن
غضبهم بعد ما اسفر الحريق عن مقتل عدد من
الاشخاص روايه قتل المبنى الشاهق ان فتى
الحكومه الصينيه التي اكدت ان شاغل المبنى
تمكنوا من النزول للادوار السفلى الا ان
صحه الروايه الرسميه
بشكل اساسي حالته الاحتقان لسكان اقليم
الذي يعيش واحده من اطول قرارات الاغلاق
التي اتخذتها الحكومه الصينيه
اليوم تم تكليفنا باجراء اختبار الكبد
للحمض النووي لدي مشكله مع هذا لماذا
لاننا حبسنا ثلاثه ايام وانهينا جوله من
الاختبارات بعد الظهر امس من الواضح اننا
لسنا حالات ايجابيه او اعراضيه لكننا كنا
في حاله اغلاق لمده ثلاثه ايام اين تذهب
لتصاب بالعدوى بالامس اجرين اختبار كوبيد
في فتره ما بعد الظهر ثم طلب منها هذا
الصباح اجراء اختبار مره اخرى
هذا اولا غير ضروري وثانيا يزيد العدوى
الصين التي تدافع عن سياسه رئيسها سجن بيج
الخاصه بصفر الكوبيد سجلت في اخر احصائيه
حديثه ما يزيد على 34 الف اصابه فايروس
كورونا جديده معظمها دون اعراض وفقا للجنه
الصحيه الوطنيه الصينيه سياسه التزم بها
المسؤولون في بكين ونهجون طبق على الرغم
من المعارضه الشعبيه المتساعده وتزايد
الخسائر في ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم